tout a commencé là bas dans la ville
qu'on appelle maisons alfort
quand je vois une fatma celle où qui
fait vibrer son corps merci c'est gentil
mais je note album il a il a marqué
quelque chose parce qu'ils étaient
multidirectionnel je trouve que tout est
génial
son flow mais les instructeurs ya
quelque chose de chez pas de double
parfait et ça reste quand même un des
meilleurs moments de cette ville
[Musique]
on avait l'habitude de lancer des
expressions qu'on devait balancé dans
différents collèges à guillaume budé à
créteil au lycée technique arago et
machin et puis quand on revenait une
semaine après on vous voyez si ça avait
pris en fait on faisait on faisait des
flyers vocaux et voir si nos expressions
pouvait bouger
j'en ai fait un rap donc je faisais les
championnats du monde de dj puis à un
moment je suis tombé sur son groupe le
500m possible où il y avait stryker
dissoni m6 et lui et m6 erreur et j'ai
acheté un petit sur d'enregistrement et
je les ai invités chez ma mère en fait
dans la cave
on est où c'était tout petit c'était une
toute petite maison ce qu'on avait
toujours la tête baissée tellement le
toit était petit miracle et avec je
m'interdis on enregistre et nos trois
premières chansons lui en fait au moins
c'était un mois de juillet et travailler
au triage de villeneuve saint georges à
la poste les trier le courrier et je
vais proposer en un mois de juillet de
venir enregistrer des titres pour voir
ce que c'est ce que ce que ça allait
donner pardon et en enregistrer notre
premier titre bouffe de la caroline et
quartiers nord on en voyait ça dans des
enveloppes dans des idées j'en fais des
labels ça s'appelait n'est la belle
puis on est reçu des coups de téléphone
en disent ont passé et le fait de passer
on s'est pris un peu au sérieux
on s'est dit on va en faire d'autres
et ça a donné bush de l'appui qui sème
le vent récolte le tempo chabwani avec
en face et les bleus même si le commando
de la face je t'aime pour
roy dans l'arène musicale
oh
vraiment une bande de potes qui on
découvrait tous l'europe ils étaient
américains à la base et tout d'un coup
et avec quelques mecs qu'il va lancer en
français et on était là mais on comprend
ce qu'il dit c'est génial
et en plus c'était bien ce qu'ils disent
est donc ça avait beaucoup de choses
parler d'une année qu'on appelle adore
le texte de caroline mon père est
chanteur et il a repris la chanson
caroline et et ce texte je le trouve
sublime en fait je trouve que c'est une
très très belle façon de raconter une
rupture de parler de la jalousie de d'un
coeur brisé et sert metex préféré
caroline c'est quelqu'un qui est dans ma
classe au moment où j'écris je pense à
elle je conçois de quoi en même temps
mais bon je me dis tiens on peut
peut-être faire un rap là dessus mais
évidemment elle s'appelle pas caroline
mais quand j'ai trouvé cette espèce de
chose les couleurs les cartes à streiff
piqueur bon il fallait qu'elle s'appelle
carreau comme ça la chose était fait
je suis las de tête et big donc
l'aspect très typique des tonga
j'adore victime de la mode aussi qui est
un autre de mes préférés que je trouve
tellement tellement justes et
aujourd'hui encore tellement d'actualité
et puis et puis super cool en fait que
ce soit un homme qui qui qui aborde ce
sujet un victime de la mode heureusement
qu' à angèle qu'il a fait reconnaître à
des gens qui la connaissaient pas parce
que ouais un peu ce côté quand même
envie de faire un court métrage pas
méchant à l'époque des premiers
mannequin inès de la fressange et tout
ça alors par l'enregistrement j'ai su
que ce disque enfin on ne sait jamais
mais je me suis dit là on fait on est en
train de faire un truc qui ressemble
absolument rien j'écoute la musique
toute la journée est censé sortir ou de
venir là je me suis dit on a un truc je
pense même leur avoir digéré mais qu'on
a un truc de fou rire gêné les ma
démission le lendemain le rap était en
train de monter de façon toute petite
il y avait des groupes partout et puis
oui cet album est là il a marqué quelque
chose parce qu'il était
multidirectionnel il ya tous les types
de rap il ya des choses qui sont un peu
hardcore il ya de la poésie pointilliste
avec un morceau comme caroline il ya le
fun avec bouge de là il y avait beaucoup
de choses comment donc on va dire
beaucoup de choses qui étaient voilà il
ya toutes ces directions qui sont
possibles à prendre pour faire du rap en